53 players in this one 1826 average
rating war zone kings here we go all
righty can we get off to a decent start
here a decent start
alright let's kick this night away
let's kick them away now I should back
up before there's like a fork trick
stop that b5 idea okay now get my bishop
up this going on here kick the night
away right now and then get to d6 this
diagonal is open for my bishop now
Knight here looking for a fork to avoid
that exchange I want to get here
something let's try this hopefully it
works this pawn is falling huh okay take
care
do this Knight takes is with check ouch
I'm on h7 and a six Bishop takes pawn
with check this is a killer to me if the
King goes to the corner Forks Forex I
have the Queen Forks I don't want to
take this pawn let's take this and then
I'll take the pawn and then take the
bishop next okay let's just do this it's
a check
okay they were looking for tricks right
they're looking for the tricks pin that
rook just defend this pawn time
situation where are we at
so here hit that Bishop looking to just
take it next it's gotta be Forks or
right here's the fork resigned time they
resigned back determined to know got six
up there six and then a bunch of two's
Hassam are no Hassan Ahmad here we go
okay a lot of time here a lot of time
remaining here okay there's got to be
somebody out there that is still unaware
of the fishing pole right somebody
somebody out there okay
Knight right here and I get the Queen
real quick push this night away
in-betweener Knight takes I take this
night I get a piece my force I get a
piece in that dark square Bishop get rid
of the dark square Bishop okay well
we're having this instead you take my
knight let's come back I'll just take
the pawn he was free he's still free
pawn push I take let's go like this
another pond he might be trapped out
with h3 let's just do this just in case
see my mouse just sticking right there
see that
okay let's trade a little bit and then
target at what right here I guess I here
crashed through not really can I get a
fork where's their fork tricky Forks
where are you at there it is tricky
Forks tricky Forks upper rook
okay let's go past fun you are fast and
passed fast and passed right here's me I
almost miss that one back to term in
twelve twelve ten six six this is the
guy that won that tournament
oh no oh no open Sicilian they're gonna
be tricky on me here tricky against me
let's try that seems exciting seems
exciting exciting stuff should just
taken the night take a now mate
oh this is make no matter what oh that's
what I needed
back to tournament they resigned 1212
oh that was a clutch one that was kind
of quick I'll take those quick ones I
will take those quick ones whoo all
right
25 minutes remaining
blah this game is kind of like that
let's go here ah I got to do some home
cooking who the home cook on this guy
right here I'm cooking my game not
cooking
why has this one in the bag there up a
piece hit me with the air in my game I
better go back that one seems to be dead
come on
all righty nothing going on hit me with
the air and give me these points this
did play a role in the one not uploaded
to YouTube it was exactly how what I
needed in air with the amount of time
remaining still nothing going on here
leaders I'm still up there barely come
on hit me with the points look at the
clock
yes err give me points give me the
points give me the points I got four out
of it
let's take two four give me the four
give me the four and let's play Oh No
what's going on am I gonna air my way to
victory
watch this be the rest of the No we got
it we got action we got action you know
what I was getting at imagine that
imagine that the rest of the tournament
went down like that yeah that's a great
way to win that's a great way to win
this guy the stakes are doubled stakes
have been doubled let's go night Oh
night g4 9g for still Knight g4 still
give me the a file I got the a file I'm
not afraid of that take my night doubled
pawns aren't a problem not here no okay
IBF file let's go at file I want to keep
the Queen's on the board I usually don't
want to do that or usually I'm open to
trading but I see this is a better
position for me at this pawn I want to
get to f5 they must be scared pick up a
pot on the way forks forks everywhere
East 747 4th Red Alert red alert Red
Alert
there goes the Queen gone in a blink hit
the pond get out of there Knight come
over here hit the knight again he's
cooked he's cooked no he's not go here
stop him from going here though oh he's
gonna take there though tricky Knight
let me tell you I'm just gonna take him
oh I thought they would have taken my
queen they didn't take my queen
Pig one Pig where's the other one
where is the other Pig right here right
here and check here let's go here we go
here we go mate next move no matter what
back to tournament twenty four twenty
two twenty twenty two minutes remaining
here we go less than twenty two
remaining no fries no no I know what's
coming I know I could be coming any
moment at any moment it could happen
let's take here I have to stop that pawn
push maybe okay I'm on this pond let's
go here pawn push is gonna happen or is
it Oh Brooke on c8 this is tight this is
tight here let's go
get out of there night I cannot deal
with you anymore I'm mad at you I'm mad
at you I can't deal with you anymore
oh here we go right here is juicy juicy
square II get to ee4 my LightSquared
bishop would love to play one day you
would love to play one day no right here
tempo Gaynor tempo Gaynor
connected pass pine hmm now let's go
here oh the night's gonna jump in there
let's take the good versus bad Bishop
ending let's go to this pawn push the
Knights such a pain
okay connect to pass pine right here
lock everything down over here over here
watch out for sneaky e4 moves
what's my clock situation I don't have
much time oh I shouldn't have locked it
up like that uh can I break this open
somehow over here how can I
this is it winter bull I got to go with
the pawn maybe take my pond please okay
my bishop needs to weasel around where
can it weasel - are you talking about oh
okay over here is this is even doing
anything what is that doing you know
what I have to try I have to go in this
direction oh they gave me that pond
let's come over here now we're here
right here okay I have this right
position-wise clockwise though is
another story
Oh clock situation oh I got these two at
least oh come on I can't breathe again
watch out for steal me watch out for
stalemate could happen at any moment
watch out for a stalemate they're not
moving they're down on time I sorry God
Nona fried at the end of that one that
was okay they probably didn't know where
to go or something they were short on
squares that looked like it might have
been me was it me it wasn't made they
would have called it right let's do this
let's try this line I think it's not
good but let's give it a shot let's give
it a shot here wow I was a nail-biter
huh how do you think
let's go LightSquared bishop bishop here
pawn push here we go I got a successful
break-in and I'm not gonna take it I
want my knight to be the one that gets
to e6 with the deadly fork but deadly
for the Queen is close to dead I like my
knight there too much I don't even want
to take the rook pins everywhere as well
discover tricks in the air check back
here more checks they resigned back to
tournament 5852 the guy that I beat is
back up there what is he doing he's
still around that guy does not go away
he must have rebounded with the fishing
pole he lost a game and then he came
right back he speared somebody with the
fishing pole take this guy ok mother
pearl entirely at the end of this after
the smoke clears smoke clears you attack
the pond I defend it you go here I have
to worry hmm over there watch out watch
out for tricky Night Moves the Queen
might go there oh man
Oh ma'am I think I got to do this that
is scary though Knight right here Queen
there was uh kind of freaking me out
there okay let's get developed
let's get developed there um okay let's
get out of tricky stuff right here avoid
the tricky stuff stop
quit bugging me here look at how much
time I wasted that Knights gonna kill me
let's come here rook let's go 25 ticks
we're gonna have a bunch of traits I'm
gonna take that let's get developed
could we get to valve please
yeah beef Ivan why'd I take with my
bishop ah right here right here next
okay just take here I need a flight
square light square flight square light
square flight square bishop here just
take them
forks I got a fork I have a fork 14th I
also have 14 seconds get out of there
get out got a pin this night whoa I'm on
the Queen I am on that Queen
I'm gonna take my bishop with a check
they're not watch out for mates watch
out for tricky mates tricky mates you
know you wanted to take the Queen she's
juicy and you want to take that let's do
this where's the mate its next right
here right here next no matter what back
to tournament 76 74 sixty nine sixty I'm
out of confetti land let's go math e joy
all right
ah man why'd you have to play c5 right
there okay let's get this in before I
play my knight to f3 okay why do I want
to go my queen let's go here my queen is
kind of running out of squares let's do
that let's do this it looks a little
crazy I'm gonna try it though launch
that Jeep on let's throw this one and
they might have been suspecting them now
let's do it
tough to coordinating let's go pawns
coordination stuff uh-oh I'm on e6 that
King can't be happy right now Kenny
let's Castle and get on the h5 I want to
get at this point pawn push here now
let's do this pin that Knight pawn push
next take the knight push the pawn jump
here get that this square the knight has
to move big trouble now big trouble with
check first let's take here oh this rook
is hit twice no no no no let's do this
first right there let's throw a check in
that's a fork and then this has to be a
killer right a killer is this a killer
this has to be a killer they should move
looking for mate soon open diagonals my
queen is also on the rook should have
done that sooner you just take that
night
my next turn no matter what
double-checked me around the corner King
g7 is double checkmate Bishop g5 this is
me double check mate next double check
mate got it back to tournament 102 76 74
what is this guy eating 102 I dropped
back I'm in 3rd 13 minutes and change
quick resigner hang on 87-85 I'm in 3rd
102 80 78574 nap this guy knows all
about the fishing pole I do I think
every time against this guy I wonder
what he wonders or she did a he or she
um okay my Center is collapsing here
it's collapsing but I do have control
over f6 which means what what does that
mean it means that what does it mean it
means possibilities for an attack
against the king that took forever to
come out but that's what I meant to say
let's break that pin my knight is ready
to roam discovered tricky stuff
discovered tricky stuff c5 be scared pin
the knight can still take on this square
actually the bishop could take tricky
Knight push here the bishop has to run
backwards that can't be fun he's got to
go can't deal with him pawn push next
grab here let's do that I don't know why
no I chased that guy way and then pawn
push here pins where are the pins
get out of there Queen pawn push next
thing come back here or something let's
come over there I'm on the Queen still
let's take that dark square Bishop yeah
look good the Queen's are gonna come off
oh I'm on the Queen they missed that
they're gonna resign 12 minutes
remaining
I think they resigned if they're down
yes whoa where I click on
I don't know doctor tournament one on to
the next game mega King mega King knows
all about the little tricks Queen c7
stuff okay let's take here this there's
not gonna be any quick kill here is
there can't be any tweener I thought
they might miss that catch him in a pre
move right here what does that deal no
no right here
I guess uh I might get this in all right
here jumping knight in there no and
right here okay no no no 94 I have an
idea took me a while to figure it out
but I think I figured it out
is it where my knight wants to be it's
gonna go back Bishop here might be good
mmm
okay we're gonna have a bunch of trades
that can't be right can it you're gonna
take that I take my knight you take my
knight I take like this get my Queen
right here right here um that pine pawn
push okay I have this pond I'm gonna
pile up in that pond it's gonna be
defended got the Queen if you take I got
the Queen okay they resigned back to
term at 142 125 107 107 10 minutes and
change hack comic 10 minutes and change
fantasy variation this could lead to a
tough situation for black because I
could get this 'if I've advanced in
we're close to it very close to it could
take that night and then grab here
actually let's defend that there's not
gonna be me I'm gonna Castle queenside
and then throw my uh my pawns around
actually let's do this right now
I think I just want to take that night
yeah grab this pawn it's a little little
scary but I want to lock down with a 4
and then uh whoa I got to get rid of
that Bishop he's too powerful
let's capture with my rook
okay I gotta get rid that light-square
bishop he's got to go he's gotta go and
now when I get it this square
okay he's gotta go looks a little scary
I want to stop Queen here kind of let's
take that there's gonna be a check sneak
over here and then I just need to get
that pawn watch out for tricks I gotta
get that pond number one priority I just
got to get the Queen's off 18 seconds
okay now um cleans off
let's get these queens off quit running
away pawn push and then I have Czech
sewing this diagonal okay let's do this
and then defend like that or something
just barely in a spot okay the knight
the rook and takes c4 with check why did
I do that clock situation it doesn't
really matter anything they're down on
time back to tournament 145 I have a
lead 145 142 oh did he drop back he he
had a loss I guess apparently I guess
apparently great words to be streamed
together right okay regroup here this is
the guy that gave me trouble last time
wasn't it oh yeah you want to do that
what a wonderful way to weaken d5 well
done well done congratulations you
weakened d5 for the remainder of the
game I should kill that Bishop soon
let's do this I should still kill that
Bishop soon
Shinae let's do it now this is like this
reminds me of what of what does it
remind me of the the very Lopez okay
let's come here
that's uh develop develop develop the
center is closed shut my night right in
here okay let's take this I had that a
move sooner and I could get this seep on
maybe even do an exchange sack come all
the way back Knight wants to jump in and
have some fun
actually let's come here I think this is
a good spot to stop my name from coming
there no light square bishop get rid of
the light square bishop and then break
at the light squares now it's a freebie
free night free bishop I mean free
bishops both bishops are free both
bishops are free take here let the night
go down just get here I hear you
recognized that this night is dead so
let's do this Bishop here discover
tricks there pins
pawn push discover checks the pin is
mightier than the sword is it where's
that move even do Queens gonna take here
why did I defend against that ah I
should just do this clean here or here
okay let's keep that the Knights in the
pin I'm hitting the rook to pin Knights
one is a true pin okay I'm on that night
twice
where are the mates I should just take
him that night okay now it's gonna be
tea kale real soon TKO real soon how
about this as well where is that me
mm-hmm double check and then mate no
matter what next no matter what Queen
takes Bishop rook takes rook they resign
no they donít I'm back to terminal 147
147 145 oh man oh I'm in the lead no no
I just didn't refresh
false alarm I have 165
was nice that was a nice surprise right
there thinking I was in third and then
hit the refresh button and then bam bam
you're in first like that with one click
of the refresh button just like that it
was the magic refresh button once again
no idea what that means no idea what
that even means let's defend this pawn
let's come here it's got to be a little
bit scary hit the Queen she's got to be
scared is she scared we're gonna see
about that yeah she is scared she gave
herself up oh let's go here the Knights
pinned temporarily the Knights gonna
come here and drop a bomb bombs away I'm
gonna take this though just trade down
if you got material I'm up a full rook I
am up a full rook let's grab this pawn
grab another one
throw a pig let's grab this guy where
are the pigs can't be easy cannon I'm
gonna push I gotta track that pond down
he's getting too out of hand
- out of hand let's go pawn your past
and fast watch out for mates watch out
for mates watch out for mates tricky
mates what am i doing what a stupid move
that last one was ah okay I still have
this but why did it take forever to do
that it was an easier way wasn't there
there was an easier way wasn't there
here we go
run pawn fast and passed fast past pawns
are fast pawns 185 167 there one went
away from jumping in there three minutes
39 seconds
can you tell it's getting more intense
can you tell let's go I need to pick up
a quick winner that night is converted
to a queen side piece that means it's
not around to defend the Kings side oh
oh oh oh oh oh let's go right here put a
piece right here right here right here
you know you want to do that huh get out
of there Knight
I want to get here with the bishop or
something let's do this jump my knight
right in here that's a good plan isn't
it let's take here first take your next
bishop here with the check somehow back
up my knight where does it want to be
right here bishop check bishop check oh
man there's got to be something juicy
here right uh hit that bishop my light
square bishop would love to play I'm on
this making one threat meet one meeting
one meeting one come on uh oh why did I
do that why did I do that what's the
clock situation 225 very little time
give me that Bishop need to get rid of
that guy okay
forks where are you
what's my queen side doing what's my
queen side doing ah stupid Queen side
you're doing nothing and this guy is
dead no it's not no it's not dropping
stuff 13 seconds
can I get some activity here where's the
activity I have no activity right here I
stopped that there we go oh I dropped
upon no no no no no no no I can't go
there
I gotta go here don't make me please
don't make me run to the corner it's
safe there isn't it it's me it's no it's
not is this me no I gotta give a check
and get rid of stuff no let's go here
first I don't have any time no time no
time no time no time
I lost I lost I lost I just needed to
make a move
oh no no no no I was trying to just make
a move and I knew it oh no no no no no
no no no I need a quick kill plane until
playing on tilt I'm playin on tilt oh no
no no no no no it can't be
oh man I had that one in the bag didn't
I ah didn't I have that one in the bag I
had it in the bag man ah
40 seconds are they just gonna resign
can I get a quick resigner this guy
doesn't resign yes he does 203 203 I'm
definitely out of first can I get a
quick resigner 25 ticks down to the wire
down to the wire where we at man that
one's done so bad oh man I wanna go
first either are ya I would have because
I lost that game and dropped back ah was
a decider oh man it doesn't matter
this kid tournaments over they're
calling it they're calling it a thanks
for playing oh no that would hurt so bad
you have no idea
you really don't you cannot appreciate
how bad it hurts oh man let's see what
would have been I dropped back to I
would have been at 205 okay even if I
won I would have been at 225 second
place only good enough for a second but
no confetti
oh good games
good games off